normally
lying to the police does not implicate
jail time
i have a problem with punishing people
for lying to the police or lying to the
fbi because
the law allows the fbi and the police to
lie to you so if they can lie do you
remember the martha stewart case they
lied to her in the same conversation in
which she lied to them the fbi agent who
lied to her got a promotion she went to
jail for six months for lying to them
did you feel covering
from oj to to all the stuff that you
were covering on fox for you know 15 20
years uh actually more uh did you feel
that there is a risk in doing some of
that day to day on on cable news that
you have to be more sensational or that
you maybe aren't privy to all the
information that's going on in the
courtroom or you got to keep people
watching and no you know one of the
things that i find tough when you when
you follow court cases these days the
way everyone seems to do on cable news
we're suddenly privy to all of this
information that maybe we all shouldn't
be privy to all the time or at least the
public shouldn't care about every little
in and out of every little thing how do
you try to blend that i agree with you
the public shouldn't care about every
little in and out and and every little
thing but in this era of cable news
we do i don't know how the founding
fathers would have fared if cable news
had been around not well not well
um you know fox had and has terrific
researchers
they also allowed me to hire my own
researcher a lawyer
in between fox's researchers known
affectionately as the brain room uh and
my researcher i i was able to
to devour what i needed to know
occasionally you make a mistake
sometimes the mistake leads
to a lawsuit but remember you're
explaining things
for the public you're not making an
argument before the supreme court so you
don't
you don't need to know everything the
key is to explain it so that the public
understands it appreciates the
explanation and wants more of it
okay so with that in mind let's switch
to some of the issues of the day so you
brought up the jesse smellette thing
which we covered a whole bunch over the
last few weeks so he gets sentenced ever
there's really no one other than him i
suppose and his lawyer who's claiming
that he's still innocent i mean it's
it's sort of bananas and everyone saw
the diatribe at the end during the
sentencing
he gets the 150 days in jail and a
couple other things but basically he's
going to serve a week in jail and that's
it they're going to let him out
what do you make of
the sentencing
then the shortening of the sentencing
and just the media part of this and and
how do you think the judge had to deal
with the media portion of it okay the
media is not easy to deal with in the
era that i was on the bench dave cameras
were not permitted
in courtrooms and in the few courtrooms
in which they were permitted the judge
had an absolute right to exclude them
today you can't exclude them in federal
court they're not permitted but in state
courts they're there all the time
they're tiny
uh they don't make any noise after a
while you forget that they're there but
they are there which is why we all know
more detail than we need to know
i thought his sentencing was fair
normally
lying to the police does not implicate
jail time
i have a problem with punishing people
for lying to the police or lying to the
fbi because
the law allows the fbi and the police to
lie to you
so if they can lie do you remember the
martha stewart case they lied to her in
the same conversation in which she lied
to them the fbi agent who lied to her
got a promotion she went to jail for six
months for lying to them so wait a
minute
quick sidebar on that i was a pa on
martha stewart's talk show when she came
back after jail time and she still had
the monitor on her foot when she was
doing the show
when she came to fox she asked for me
and hugged and kissed me
we are we are from two towns next to
each other bloomfield new jersey and
nutley new jersey bloomfield very
italian at the time
polish her name is no more stewart than
minus smith but she she promoted that
very uh very well now back to uh jesse
because the lies were regular consistent
systematic and because the government
wasted 125 to 150 000 investigating the
lies i believe that the jail sentence of
150 days
and the restitution to the government
was appropriate now his sentence was not
shortened he was let off on appeal
it's an interesting reason why i was lit
off on appeal because if he started
serving 150 days immediately he would be
finished with it before the appeal would
ever even be heard because it takes a
year or two for the appellate courts to
hear your appeal because the appeals get
online on the basis of when they were
filed
so he's still facing 150 days
in jail unless the appellate court
decides either that he was wrongfully
convicted or that he was over punished i
don't think either is the case
right
in a situation like that so when they
finally get to it do they usually just
say ah we're sort of past this thing and
just let them go at this point
well no because the prosecutors will be
pounding the table the the the appellate
court would have to find
that the trial was unfair that the trial
judge made mistakes of such a magnitude
uh that he was not proven guilty or that
the sentence was unfair the sentence was
not unfair was well within the range
that the statute allowed so his only
hope
is to find that because the first
prosecutor said i'm not going to
prosecute you they shouldn't have
assigned it to a second prosecutor
that's his only hope
uh on appeal that once a prosecutor said
we're not prosecuting you
uh
that that was it
most states once a prosecutor says we're
not going to prosecute you they don't
send it to another prosecutor they did
it
because jesse became very very unpopular
in the chicago community now you
shouldn't be prosecuted just because
you're unpopular you should be
prosecuted if there's enough evidence to
convict and if your behavior has caused
harm
where does that
that if your behavior has caused harm
where does that go when it comes to the
prosecuting meaning that
in terms of the actual crime he
committed
you know to set up this hoax there's not
a lot of damage done but i think you
could argue that there was a tremendous
amount of damage done to society to the
city of chicago but the whole country in
terms of this culture war that we're
fighting how often do you think judges
are affected by that that there's a much
bigger fight at play than the specifics
of oh okay he paid these two guys he
made up this thing that we could kind of
look past but it's really that you could
argue that then there were more riots
because of this or just the general
flame of the culture war continues
because of something like this so that
cannot be taken into account at the time
of sentencing but here's something that
can be that i think will interest you
and the folks listening to us now
when i told you there's a checklist 25
aggravating and 25 mitigating factors
one of the aggravating factors is
the defendant committed this crime as a
cost of doing of doing business
now that was put in there because of
mafia guys who committed crimes as a
cost of doing business
and the judge in my opinion quite
properly did
check that box jesse concocted this
whole thing
as a cost of doing business now
he and i ultimately had the same bosses
because we both worked for fox
well he's crazy to think that he's going
to get a leg up but
fox in this nonsense maybe had another
network but not at fox they'd be sorry
that it happened but that's not going to
uh not going to help uh the careers
but back to your question the only harm
was to the government
the only harm traceable to his behavior
was a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
in police overtime investigating an
event that never occurred
now he was charged with six lies because
they interrogated him six times
and each time he gave them the same
nonsensical story he was convicted of
five we won't know why without asking
the jurors
the the sixth one
did not result in a conviction each of
those
uh could have been three years in jail
he ended up with a 150 days
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversation about law
instead of the non-stop yelling you get
everywhere else check out our law
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell